l'arrivée de l'automne rappelle que
c'est ici que tout a commencé que c'est
ici que le mot terrorisme a soudainement
pris une dimension aux canadiennes à
quelques pâles doit été fauchée
l'adjudant patrice vincent on en parle
comme si c'était arrivé hier sa première
fois quand ces gens il ya une chose
comme ça ça pas de bon sens on y pense
on sait que ça existe c'est que ce n'est
pas si petit que ça repose du sang lors
dans une ville où il existe une longue
tradition militaire la question de la
sécurité a toujours eu une résonance
particulière aux mois après l'attentât
difficile d'oublier ce qui s'est produit
ici
après midi deux parties de cartes à la
région de saint-jean-sur-richelieu des
vétérans de tout âge et leurs proches
viennent régulièrement et faire leur
tour ils opinion sur la sécurité sont
toutes aussi variées que leur stratégie
non mais tu en mangeras pas les gens
aussi à quoi ça peut ça peut devenir de
pire en p1
ça ne m'a pas fait part mais je me dis
nous arriver mais je me sens en sécurité
tout autant que n'importe quel autre
canadien mais faut quand même être
vigilant
ils sont conscients de l'évolution du
débat sur la sécurité tout comme de
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
antiterroriste ce club de sécurité ça
nous donne confiance aux cayes la
protection c'est bien certain mais
encore là tous n'ont pas la même vision
des choses avec ce bébé là on sait pas
jusqu'où ça pourrait aller on se pose
des questions savoir qui va contrôler
quoi il ya des grosses questions à
coarraze transpose elle devra être
modifiée par pape a aboli mais bonne
file les risques d'atteinte à la vie
privée des canadiens en dérange certains
pour d'autres la loi antiterroriste
reflète la réalité d'aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça va trop loin quand vous
que tout l'espace est ce qui est arrivé
à ottawa mais faut pas regarder que de
payer non plus on regarde l extérieur de
la france qui est élevé est vrai que ça
pendant la chaux du juste milieu
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez ils ont
vécu de près le même événement et
pourtant d'une table à l'autre
la loi c 51 rassure autant qu'elle
soulève des craintes
et si marc godbout radio-canada à
saint-jean-sur-richelieu